what you're about to watch is a clip
from my brand lytics training where i
get together with entrepreneurs thought
leaders who want to build their brand
using youtube and making data driven
decisions to blow up their brand this
year enjoy
i want to talk about end mid and
pre-roll placements or advertisements to
help spread more awareness
for what you're doing
so ending cta this is something that i'm
experimenting with brendan burchard
so brendan and i partnered up on his
uh
a bunch of things that one of them is
his growth day youtube channel
and the goal is strictly get people to
sign up for growth day what is growth
day growth day is his new personal
development
program app uh it's designed to
every ideally every day have somebody
going live people who you know like
respect
training on personal development it
could be brandon could be mel robbins
could be david bach dave hollis um all
these people to have them train and then
you pay one monthly fee and then you
sign up
what we're doing is doing clips of his
videos and this this is part of his
morning show but this is going to expand
having clips as his videos
and then on the end card
is brendan saying hey if you want to
like today's the day you want to learn
you want to grow you want to sign for
growth day go click the link on this
page
and this is blank right now because we
just started the channel have to get the
4 000 hours of watch time
to be able to qualify so we've got the
thousand subscribers now we just need
the 4 thousand hours watch time
but this is going to be a link that
people can then click
to go off and sign up for growth day
it's less of a
let's build the channel up
that's more of a long term play let's
build the channel up let's get tons of
subscribers to learn about grote and
more immediate at the end of every video
let's promote growth day and get them to
click on the link
right
we have found tremendous success i don't
know if i've talked about side inside of
brandlytics yet but we found tremendous
success with on the end card just having
one big call to action
instead of having multiple
so typically if you go back on my
channel you'll see that we had four
things on the end card there was the
video that you pick another video or
playlist that you pick a subscribe
button and a link to my website
and we found that as an experiment we
just tried one and on most of my videos
if you go and look at my my content now
you'll see there's one big call to
action which is to watch another video
so if you want more from xyz go click
the video right there i'll see you there
you're gonna love it
and then looking and pointing to to go
there
the clicks on that one
video
are getting more clicks than the other
four elements combined
so now if you look at the channels
you'll see like these arrows flying in
and people that we're doing work you
know consulting helping with
recommending the same thing um different
styles of arrows but basically all these
arrows looking pointing like go click on
this thing
so it's worth a test i haven't done
enough and i don't know enough people
who are doing the ending ctas like this
to drive to an offer instead of another
video
but it's worth an experiment
to see hey this is an option for me
because in my end card and you're in
cards you can link to another video
provided you're in the partnership
program and if you're not it's at least
something you know about that you can
build towards
but it could make a big difference for
getting people
to click over to your site it's his new
big passion project
um turning it into an app or i think the
app is actually already out or it's
about to
be out um
yeah it's awesome to see so much change
in addition to the personal development
field so this is something to play with
i don't do it on my main channel but
we're doing it for brendan on his growth
day because the number one goal is get
people into growth day
ashley this could be an experiment for
one of your videos right hey this is
from our tapping app you want to sign up
for it it's right there go click it
check it out and measure to see how many
clicks you're getting from it
so that's the ending cta
what i usually do
is the mid shadow and this is
much easier to
uh
implement as well as
not impact where people go next because
if you're doing this one
we're having a heavy focus on getting
people to go to somewhere else besides
youtube
where if your goal is to grow the
channel and make it as big as possible
you want to increase watch time and so
you want to have a video at the end that
you're guiding people towards
and it's always much better to have you
picking the most relevant video and you
calling out that specific video to go
check out than just having best reviewer
or or most recent
okay
i do this one a lot myself personally so
somewhere in the middle of every video
we have some kind of call to action so
this is one that i did for the book
so
one of the advice that brendan gave me
for the book is have different people
read the book he said one of his biggest
strategies to help him launch his book
was he had people like larry king and
all these other people
uh read a section from the book and he
turned that into video content to help
promote the book
so my first question was okay would you
be my first brendan do you want to read
the book
and he said yes and my heart was beating
asking for that and then i used that and
got other people so
a lot of my videos probably half of the
videos
on my main channel will have a mid
shout out here of somebody
reading the book so this is an example
of j shetty but you know we've got
uh grant cardone and and
kevin o'leary and ed my lead and
lots of people in in personal
development that you probably know and
recognize and then it's check the link
in the description to get your copy
so we're interrupting our video in the
middle this one is at this is a 30
something minute video and this happens
at the 10 56 mark
so somewhere in the middle of the video
if you do this kind of
shout out
at the beginning of the video you're
going to lose people because they don't
know who you are they're not ready for
an offer your retention is going to
going to drop
if you do it at the end
like this one
you're also going to lose a lot of
retention because they just feel that
it's a pitch
what's the advantage is you can actually
have them click right here instead of
having to click in the description
when you do it in the middle
there's usually very little retention
drop
because you've gotten them to watch in
this case you know 11 minutes of a video
so they're they're interested they're
engaged
and they know that there's still another
you know 20 minutes left
so they want to stick around for what's
coming next
uh so
tom bilyeu has changed his strategy and
does a good job of this now where he'll
have a super quick mention at the
beginning but he'll interrupt his own
interviews
at an appropriate point to talk about
whoever the sponsor is of the video
so somewhere in the middle of the video
in the most appropriate place possible
normally for something like this you
know if we're doing 10 hard choices you
need to make in life uh we've probably
included a j shetty
compilation a video somewhere here and
then right after you watch the j shetty
clip there's jay shetty reading the book
right after you're watching grant
cardone interviewed like there's grant
cardone and i talking about the book
so this is to get people to
click the link it's in the description
we can't have it you know clickable here
as a big button like we can with other
ones
but we can have them to go click on the
link down below
uh
drew says
is that mid shadow baked into the video
or you buy the ad slot this is baked
into the video this is organic baked
into the video you could buy add spots
as well and we'll talk about that the
pre-world is usually better than the mid
because we time it specifically
around something that i'm talking about
so j shetty shows up after j shady clip
grant cardone shows up after grant
cardone clip the even the topic so jay
shetty would read this section he read
was about relationships
uh
talking to
grant cardone or somebody else is going
to be slightly different topic there's
different parts in the book the brendon
richard one talked about purpose the
clip that he read from my book so also
trying to match it with the theme of the
video
so if you're thinking about you're
making a video you're gonna have a call
to action somewhere in the middle
while you're talking about your content
if you're gonna make a 20 minute video
or ten minute video
at what point
somewhere in the middle you know like in
the one third the two-thirds mark
does it make the most relevant sense
to talk about whatever offer you've got
so you can customize it when you're
buying a mid-roll ad spot that makes it
a lot you it's a lot more difficult you
could do it it's a lot more manual to
like put a manual ad spot right here and
then to target that with your own ad
um
and this is organic and free
so it's a constant driver people keep
watching this video
this kind of thing is better for
a consistent ongoing offer so
i'm still going to care about build to
serve in five years it's not just my
20 21 marketing strategy and then i'm
moving on to something else because i
don't care about the book anymore like
it's it's a part of me i care about it
it's deeply important to me so i'm okay
with this living inside my video for the
next five years this is not good for
i'm launching this thing next week
go sign up
right because most of the views will not
happen inside the next week
if you want to see this full video as
well as train live with me twice a month
to blow up your brand join the brand
linux training program there's a link to
join right there next to me continue to
believe i'll see you there